Lancez la poursuite avec les go sharks où
ils poursuivent la chaloupe dont
nous avons tiré une partie dans un endroit où
nous ajoutions l'île à l'
arrière-plan, puis nous avions un petit
emplacement de réservoir d'eau avec une chaloupe sur un cardan
pour une interaction directe  avec des gens et
un puits d'eau, nous avons ensuite créé un autre
environnement dans lequel nous avons tourné sur une
scène à écran bleu dans un intérieur, donc
dans cette séquence, vous pourriez
passer d'un emplacement à un tir de réservoir
à un écran bleu
en quelques secondes  et notre travail consistait à essayer de
nous assurer que nous créions l'
eau cg et les extensions océaniques CG autour d'
elle pour correspondre suffisamment bien à l'emplacement de l'action en direct
pour qu'il se mélange, nous avons en quelque
sorte le meilleur des deux mondes, nous avons la
partie numérique à  main et nous avons les
éléments pratiques qui ont été tournés et mis en scène dans
chacun de ces plans c'est toujours une
combinaison cela dépend de ce qui fonctionne le
mieux
[Musique]